i just love um listening to this guy um
and everything that goes on between his
temples it makes me smarter every single
time i talk to bomani jones and he is
back here on the show his podcast the
right time with bomani jones can be
acquired we're all podcasts are acquired
and game theory with bomani jones soon
coming to hbo back here on the rich
eisen show
it's bomani jones how are you sir i'm
good man how about you i am uh as i just
said better for always talking to you
all right so the weekend uh what uh does
the
greatest
football weekend that i've ever seen
leave uh you thinking about bomani
that patrick mahomes is 25 and 326 and
josh allen is 25. yeah like we got brady
manning here if things go as they're
supposed to and i also think an
underrated thing with mahomes and it's
not like though we underrate patrick
holmes i mean that'd be kind of a crazy
thing to say but at the same time this
is four straight afc championship games
and i'm not a person that ascribes to
the whole quarterback wins argument but
there's a reason why they didn't go with
alex smith and they are going with this
guy right
and i'm trying to think the last time
somebody did this i think was jim kelly
well i mean the afc yeah i mean uh
reid did it in philadelphia and it was
uh donovan mcnabb who did that you know
all those years so
um it has been a while since we've seen
it in this conference to say the least
and you know
i'm with you with al and mahomes and why
not that was incredible
and even my home said i'll remember this
for the rest of my life as he went and
he found him you hugged out josh allen
but it does also obscure uh the kid
who's coming into mahomes house this
week
doing what we've never seen before go
from first overall pick to a
championship game in two years for the
bengals after he did what he did in lsu
i mean borrow's probably raising his
hand saying don't forget about me right
i assure you he is if there's anything
that joe burrow is
able to remind you of it's how good joe
burrow is and you know what i'm here for
i am okay with that i'm trying to figure
out like how exactly you get to be that
guy with that level of confidence
considering the path right and he
believes in himself and they won that
game even though he got sacked nine
times and that's joe pearl getting
sacked nine times some of those are on
him but joe burrows the guy who does
like the reason why he's the number one
pick is because of how well he moves in
the pocket and the ability to get away
with that stuff and they still won the
game like they are loaded in a lot of
ways almost i mean these are the
cincinnati bengals let us not forget the
last time before this year they won a
playoff game it was against the houston
oilers they don't even exist
yeah and they and and the team that the
oilers became doesn't exist in the
playoffs now because of him as well
you know absorbing all their heads
that's that that's because of ryan ted
hill like what one thing i have figured
out josh allen is a bit of an exception
on this though he managed to improve but
if you don't think a quarterback is that
guy he probably ain't gonna become that
guy and i think people talk themselves
into ryan tannehill in spite of like
seven years of evidence to the contrary
once things rolled well for them in
tennessee and then he went out there and
then completely boo boo to bed in this
biggest moment for them so you are a
part of the camp bomani jones that the
tennessee titans
um need to move on from ryan tannehill
well the problem is move on to where
like the the weird thing about the nfl
like a crazy market efficiency that it
has as an operation is that there are 32
starting quarterback jobs in not 32
starting quarterback like when you
really think about it there's something
fundamentally wrong with the rules of
the game if it's that hard to find
somebody who's capable of playing
quarterback in a ways where you got more
than just a handful of teams that have a
legitimate chance at getting it so if
you say okay well we're moving on for
ryan tannehill what you gonna do trade
for russell wilson like who is this
other person that you're going to bring
in that's necessarily going to improve
your situation good luck with that guys
belmont jones here on the rich eisen
show and it's interesting you you i
totally agree with you that you know
it's it's kind of you know your spidey
sense or your gut feeling when you see a
quarterback and if he's not the guy then
he's probably not the guy right and yet
the 49ers are starting in the nfc
championship game a quarterback who
looks like the guy and then looks like
the guy who definitely isn't the guy
sometimes in the same drive right in
jimmy garoppolo it's kind of crazy when
you think about it he never looks like
the guy to me like
it looks like them dudes are open like
uh dolly foster has made a great point
about podcasting you can't imagine how
frustrating it is for kyle shanahan that
you draw up all this amazing cute quirky
stuff that just gets these guys butt
naked open and jimmy might close his
eyes before he throws the ball in the
super bowl right and where i give
shanahan credit though is
he will absolutely just say you're not
going to mess this up for us like in
that game in the playoffs uh two years
ago he's just like we're going to run
the ball the entire second half you're
not going to let jimmy mess this up for
us he'll do that if it comes down to it
but we don't have to
nobody said about the cincinnati
offensive line they gave up nine sacks
but they did enough to win so we don't
have to tell that lie about jimmy
garoppolo either
and so uh for him to also be in the nfc
championship game against stafford
because stafford was one of the
quarterbacks that uh that kyle shanahan
was kicking the tires on to see if he
could be
uh acquired and then the ram snuck in
and grabbed him the fact that they're
playing each other for the right to play
in the super bowl is kind of wild
yeah and stafford i still don't know
what to make of him do you know what to
make of him because i still don't know
what to make well i guess we're going to
find out in the next week or two right
although you know you got to give it up
though i mean what happened in tampa was
mind-blowing i mean it really gave
it it stretched the limits of the the
old saw that you don't give tom brady
extra chances
and um
none of the extra chances that brady was
afforded was afforded was stafford's
fault even the ball that got snapped
past him you know um and he's the one
that actually put his foot in the ground
and found cup and made the throw that
jimmy g didn't make to emanuel sanders
in the super bowl you know what i'm
saying so you're right and i think the
thing with stafford is stafford's
problem is inconsistency inconsistency
generally speaking like i think we have
held out hope on matt stafford in a way
that we normally don't do for number one
overall picks this is year 13 and people
like you know i don't think i still
think he's figuring it out right wow
you've gotten a lot of leeway in trying
to figure this out but he's got a great
offensive coach and they got an offense
where the number two receiver is odell
beckham and the number one receiver is
out here just killing the world
completely killing the world and so if
you give those throws staffers going to
make a lot of them and mcvay's going to
give you throws that you're able to make
like we saw jerry golf get this team to
a super bowl at some point so it's
worked out fantastically for him and i
can't knock him for making throws that
are available they look really good in
that game against that one now he's
gonna look at this next game we're gonna
see bomani jones the right time with
bomani jones podcast where all podcasts
are acquired right here on the rich
eisen show what's your take on aaron
rodgers in the season that he just had
uh on off the field um and uh and then
obviously his future after what we saw
in the whole offseason leading up to
this point
where he didn't advance as far as he did
last year
yeah you know i got a general
frustration with people who think
they're smarter than they are and want
to tell you how smart they are and all
it does is expose if they're not as
smart as they say they are right like
like i try not to let that obscure my
view of the fact that he was really
really really good this year and they
did not get it done in this last game
but that gets me to like a theoretical
place that i've been wondering about him
and that team for a long time which is
i understand all the arguments about
this is a passing league and you need to
pass to be successful in the nfl and
that's absolutely true but something
that's really important to understand
and remember about the nfl there's a
reason why
the minnesota vikings play in a dome and
the minnesota golden gophers do not
and that's because the football season
ends in november
at the university of minnesota it
doesn't get so cold that you need a dome
in december
it gets even colder in january and so
the packers have a game that's built
around throwing the ball with aaron
rodgers and best case scenario is to get
home field advantage which is to say we
are playing for the opportunity to try
to throw the ball all around the yard
that is lambeau field and so you wind up
with aaron rodgers throwing a frozen
brick around in january if everything
goes the way that you want it to go that
just seems to be like a fundamental flaw
in how you can how you construct a team
but that's where the large sample
analytics are going to get you in
trouble often in the playoffs because
the conditions that you play in are
probably not going to be the same as
everything else now is that why aaron
rodgers didn't play well at this game
not necessarily i think that's a larger
point that they got to make and now i
don't know what they're supposed to do
in sum total with the team because i
don't know if they can keep him and put
together a team that's capable of
winning a super bowl but they absolutely
do not believe they have a quarterback
behind it well
if they did they would have handled a
lot of things a lot differently right
and and and you know i had a
conversation with andrew brant long-time
executive with the packers former
capologist in in in the first hour he
says that if if they wanted to run it
back one more time with rogers they
could figure it out cat wise to keep
this thing intact
for one more year and that you know
jordan love would would wind up uh in
the end having sat as long as rogers did
waiting for his turn behind farve
um but my my the drama in my estimation
concerns
how do you have the conversation about
about doing that and sticking if one of
the two really deep down wants to leave
right and then who's the first to say it
you know i mean like if i'm the packers
and i just say you know what i could run
it back one more year with rogers uh
it's entirely possible
um but i'm not going to ask rogers
you're thinking of leaving because that
might make the complicated fellow think
they want me to leave you know what i
mean like there's a lot of communication
that needs to go down i don't know how
how that works to make sure everyone's
on the same page you know what i'm
saying yeah i don't think he wants to
leave like it sounds like they got
whatever the problems were figured out
but does he want to say if they can't
figure out how to get devonte adams to
say sure i don't know but i don't
i think that he was going through a
thing and one thing about aaron rodgers
we can reasonably trust that he's going
to tell us what he thinks and he tells
us the relationship has gotten better so
i'm inclined to believe that it has but
i also he's 38 years old like tom
brady's made us forget how old 38 is and
if aaron bradley said i don't want to do
this anymore i wouldn't be terribly
surprised especially if they still be
swabbing his nose next year
i'll be honest with that i didn't i
didn't see you finishing your sentence
that way i'll be very honest with you
about the money
i didn't see that one coming that was
that was one of those uh lord charles
curveballs that got uh that snapped off
in my direction bomani jones here on the
rich eisen show what do you think
brady's going to do
what do you think
that's a great question i wouldn't be
surprised if he retired except he played
so well that there's no reason for him
to believe that he can't play well next
year which would then make him want to
come back but i warn him as i warn all
of them
i think the only two examples you really
have of like the great quarterback that
didn't go out on a somewhat embarrassing
note is i got roger stall back in john
elway uh john i guess joe montana also
but everybody else man the end wasn't
good because nobody could walk away so i
can only assume that he's not going to
walk away
last one for you um what uh what's your
stance on the overtime uh as you know
the rules for overtime uh placed front
and center over the last 48
because of the way um the bills in
chief's classic ended where do you stand
on the nfl overtime rules it is a
tiebreaker and i mean if they flip the
coin i'd be okay with it
like it is a tiebreaker that's the thing
you you probably should have come out on
top otherwise i don't mind that the
bills didn't get the ball back i guess
it's maybe because i grew up with the
other rules for so long i haven't given
it a great deal of thought but nah it
was a great game unfortunate had to hurt
if you're a buffalo fan oh well
really so you you you think that that um
you'd even go back to the old ways where
it's just the first team to kick a field
goal
wins
i ain't gonna lie i'm not like most
people like most people are like yo we
get free football but sometimes all i
just wanted a large you know what i'm
saying like i didn't i don't i didn't
need i didn't need you to supervise me
with these fries like i'm just ready for
this game to be over a lot of those
times like i can imagine if i was
sitting out there in the cold i wouldn't
give them score first let's just get
into war
[Laughter]
bomani thanks for the time um how's the
hbo stuff coming along for you we're
moving man we're going to be able to
tell you the air date soon we started
doing test shooting like you know i'm
literally living the dream with this one
okay
and where are you shooting it where are
you going new york city okay
new york
fantastic well good luck with that um
can't wait to see what you're cooking up
and in the meantime we'll enjoy your
podcast the right time with bomani jones
appreciate you making this the right
time appreciate it all right man you
have a good one you take care that's
bomani jones everybody right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here